all right chris
yes chris so where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh i'm
from here which is leslie county leslie
county yeah
middlebury just caught me in the cotton
middle for it tell me about your
childhood you had with your parents when
you were a kid
uh yeah but they never was there for me
i kind of you know raised myself what
happened to mom and dad
uh well my mom was on drugs and my dad
he was
a chosen woman over me
so you ended up who raised you myself
and my grandma
how would you describe your childhood uh
it was okay what
was the roughest part of it uh
probably not having a dad yeah that
would do it
how far did you go in school i went all
the way up to
12th grade you graduated high school no
i didn't graduate
i went you know half the the year
in 12th grade oh i see so you almost
made it yeah almost
and then you went on your own and did
what what kind of jobs have you had
uh well i've been self-employed i do odd
jobs or i get out and dig roots
you know pull bark yeah
or way to eat just stuff like that so
this is a very poor part of
kentucky which is a very poor part of
the country yes what uh
what kind of money do you make a year
doing that uh
not much just barely enough to get by
but you live in a you have a trailer or
you know i live
i stay with my dad we have a little it's
a one-room two-story house
okay and uh how old are you i'm 31 31 do
you have
wife or kids or anything like that uh
yeah i have a five-year-old boy
and you're raising him no i know i don't
get to see him
you and you and his mother separated he
yeah i mean his mom told me he wouldn't
mind and stuff
and you know
i just never have you know got to have
anything to do with him yeah
when you were a young man did you have
dreams of doing something with your life
yeah you know i would like to
play professional sports or something
like that baseball basketball
and have you ever traveled you ever been
outside of kentucky
uh yeah where have you been i see i've
been to florida
michigan ohio
been to virginia north carolina
alabama louisiana
i've never been past the mississippi or
across the mississippi yeah you've been
around
have you ever considered leaving uh yes
it seems like there's very few
opportunities for you to work here
yeah there's not much around here but uh
what keeps you from from packing up and
moving somewhere else
uh this is home home is home yeah
and do you uh do you have friends and
family here that you stay in contact
with
uh yeah yeah my mom she's from
bledsoe in harlan county which isn't far
from here down the street
yeah and you know on my dad's side that
i'm
keen to almost everyone around here
right
what's the best what are the best and
worst things about
living in appalachia uh
the the well i don't there's really not
none of the video things you can say is
the best things about living around here
i guess family would be it yeah it's
beautiful here
yeah it is beautiful and you know you
can't get out and
you know make money in the mountains
where the what are the worst parts of
living here uh
everything so far away
everyone's poor a lot of drugs here
yeah yeah are you involved in that too
uh
i used to be on drugs but i'm on
suboxone now oh you are okay yeah a lot
of people use that to get off
but you're happy here sometimes
you're depressed sometimes too yeah yeah
what gets you down just
you get lonely or do you get uh yeah you
know and there not being anything to do
right do you know anything about your
family
uh the generations that came before you
uh
yeah on my dad's side
there uh my granny's brothers were
uh bank robbers back in the 40s and 50s
really yeah you know they decided that
you know
or they might have even started during
the great depression
i'm not sure but you know they decided
that they wanted to get away from here
you know
where'd they go and rob the banks i
guess is how they got rid of the move
do what where did they move where did
they move
uh well they brought banks from here all
the way to new york
and you know they got they got captured
and got put in prison
and they escaped federal prison in
lewisburg pennsylvania and you know they
went on crime spree from there to new
york and they got gunned down
by uh you know new york city police
it's on the internet yeah it's called
joseph and balor nolan with their names
these are your
your my great uncles so uh
you know living in appalachia it's a
very it's a very tough life very strong
you have to work hard to survive yeah
but it makes it makes everyone here you
know
everyone here seems very honest and very
hard working and very willing to
help their neighbor and help help people
they say your words all you got
you know people here seem to have a lot
of integrity yeah
you don't see that everywhere you go in
the country
you know with all the technological
advances that are going on in the world
appalachia seems to be kind of left
behind yeah do you feel like this is a
dying way of life
no you think this will continue yeah
yeah
you i mean like for your son you have a
son right yeah you you see him like
staying here
like you did and uh no he lives out in
the
western part of kentucky in columbia
you know and his uh his mom she got
killed
back a few years ago but he stays with
her mom and she's a doctor and you know
he don't have to want for nothing so
he's taken care of
this is a very simple life yeah very i
mean what what
what's what stresses do you have what
what what do you worry about or what are
you stressed out about
uh now
how you know how i'm going to get make
you know
my next dollar yeah
it seems like a lot of the people here
are involved in drugs it seems like they
get they get
maybe bored or what what do you think
the causes of all the addiction stories
you see
most mostly boredom
it just gets kind of you know there's
nothing else to do around here
but get high the pain killers were the
beginning of it
right yeah you know they was
paint pills really aren't a big thing
anymore so crystal meth has taken over
yeah well it's ice it's not really
crystal meth
it's a lot weaker than crystal meta
but it is methamphetamine
can you imagine what your life would
have been like if you had been born in a
big city like
chicago or atlanta something like that
[Music]
no not really
i know have you been to some of the
larger cities
yeah i used to live in richmond okay
how did you like that i liked it i was
in high school
whenever i you know lived down there i
went to
model laboratory school
it's on eku campus it's a private school
i i had a lot of them you know had
or i could have you know probably went
somewhere if i would have stayed up
there
but you're still a young man you still
have many years ahead of you
there's you can do many different things
right you have any plans for
for anything you'd like to do or do you
want to just stay here and dig up roots
and ginseng
well you know you know i'd like to
get a job you know steady paying job but
you know everything's far away
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
uh probably
i always be honest and
you know karma always comes back on you
or you reap what you sow as the bible
says
are you religious uh yeah i believe in
god but i wouldn't
say you know i'm really religious
religion seems to be important to a lot
of people in this in this region
yeah it is
you know i believe women's gotta wear
skirts and
long sleeves and all that and now you
know
i don't believe that way
and some people handle snakes
are you pentecostal uh
no i guess i went to church of god
no i don't believe you know women should
have to wear long sleeves and all that
that's
pentecostal that's the way they believe
that's part of the pentecostal yeah
i guess i you i you would just say i'm a
christian
all right chris well thank you so much
for talking with me all right thank you
good luck with wherever your life goes
from here
all right all right thank you